que existen,
que muestran verdadero valor, que reúne a personas,
y alentar a nuestros hijos a identificarse con las heroínas
y decir: «Quiero estar en su equipo»
porque van a estar en su equipo.
Cuando le pregunté a mi hija cuál era su personaje favorito de «Star Wars»
¿Saben lo que respondió?
Obi-Wan.
Obi-Wan Kenobi y Glinda.
¿Qué tienen en común estos dos?
Tal vez no es solo el vestido brillante.
Creo que son expertos.
Creo que estas son las dos personas en esas películas
que saben más que nadie,
y les encanta compartir sus conocimientos con otras personas
para ayudarlas a alcanzar su potencial.
Ellos son líderes.
Me gusta ese tipo de historias para mi hija,
y me gusta ese tipo de historias para mi hijo.
Quiero más historias como esa.
Quiero menos historias en las que se le diga a mi hijo:
«Ve y lucha solo»
y más historias donde se vea que su trabajo es unirse a un equipo,
tal vez un equipo liderado por mujeres,
ayudar a otras personas a mejorar
y ser mejores personas,
como el mago de Oz.
Gracias.